I'm very keen to get on to the NHS but
first if I may I just want to get your
reaction to the Westminster accounts
project launched by sky today a
transparency tool effectively for the
money that is coming into politics do
you welcome more transparency well I was
an MP when the expense is Scandal uh
broke a number of years ago and of
course we all welcome the transparency
it is very clear we all have to declare
any outside interests any outside
earnings so people can go onto the
parliament website and look for
themselves as well but I think you know
what was important during the expenses
Scandal was to try and end uh
professional politicians just being the
only route into being an MP and so you
are seeing people coming into
Westminster with outside interests I'm a
nurse I still work as a nurse I declare
those earnings on my website and then
you know cross-party we have doctors who
work in the labor party on our side in
the conservative party and I think it's
important that people are able to keep
their interests in in that sort of field
going is it certainly helps me in terms
of my work as a local constituency MP
but also as a health minister to really
see what's happening on the ground let's
bring up your own entry shall we because
you mentioned it yourself
um you can see your entry on the
database here and we can look in a bit
more detail at some of your own
donations and earnings
um the first thing if we have a look
that stands out as you mentioned the 8
890 pounds of earnings from the Royal
Marston hospital so that's your work as
a nurse that you continue to do yeah and
I guess some would argue that's you know
good example of MPS having outside but
also MPS like myself you know politics
is a Fickle game If You're Not Elected
at the next election then I would go
back to working as a nurse and you have
to keep your registration so sometimes
there's some a practical element to it
and actually my constituents really were
pleased to see me go back during covid
back onto the wards and help out where I
could and I guess it gives you a
perspective on some of the issues as
well absolutely
um you can also see that at the bottom 3
250 pounds of gifts from the betting and
gaming Council what was that
relationship so that was an event I went
to I went to to Wimbledon and a
constituent invited me who happens to
work for the betting and and gaming
Council so and that's that's what I mean
transparency is there my constituents
can look on the website parliamentary
website and ask me well what what is
that about you can see donations there
that were for the last general election
now they come to the party but if
they're allocated to you you have to
declare them and you've got a swimsuit
as well guys yeah so I so you will be
getting donations coming up to election
time I just want to have a look at the
bottom one a bit more because we can
also have a look at the total recipients
for the betting and gaming Council
another feature on the website you're
one of around 30 MPS who receive gifts
from them now on their website they say
they represent betting shops casinos
online and bingo they work to in their
words Drive High ethical standards
create a culture of safer betting and
gaming and build public and
institutional trust in our world-class
industry now as you say all these gifts
have been declared on the proper way
they're within the rules
in your views is it appropriate well my
my um example is one from a constituent
who works for them so you have to
declare yeah there's a a vested interest
there and that is to to make it open and
transparent I haven't actually been
involved in any
um uh work with the betting and gaming
Council but that's the level of
transparency that have is there any
connection at all and as a minister you
also have to declare any interest
um too and then overall on earnings we
found that MPS have earned 17.1 million
pounds today on top of their salary
since the last election and I have to
say that is overwhelmingly conservative
MPS 15.4 million pounds of that money
from conservative MPS I mean is that
okay in your opinion well I think what I
was watching the report earlier two of
those are from former Prime Ministers
and Prime former Prime Ministers do get
paid for political speeches so it's part
of their political work but I think that
the best judges of all of this will be
constituents and you know if
constituents don't feel uh that an MP is
giving 100 to their constituency
um you know they've got The Ballot Box
to make that ultimate decision and I
think you know someone like Theresa May
is you know fantastically well known for
working so hard in a constituency even
when she was prime minister she was
marshaling uh fun runs and sporting
events
um and I think the the current prime
minister is very very clear he expects
every MP to give 100 to their
constituency and it is possible to work
full-time as an MP and to do to do other
things
um you know I do night shifts and
weekends so that I don't impact on my
constituency work
um but I think it is you know it is
important that MPS do have uh come from
The Real World and that sometimes will
mean that they do have jobs outside of
parliament I guess um there's kind of
two sort of concerns people may have the
first one about whether or not MPS are
very focused on their number one job
which is big and MP and I think you kind
of touched on it there I guess the
second one is that these companies are
indirectly buying influence in
Parliament
well what I would say I mean sometimes I
do take uh take the The View that
sometimes it's always portrayed the MPS
on the make you know you know how how
long hours MPS work you know it's a
seven day a week job we work long into
the night many times a week not just in
Parliament but in our own constituencies
this week I've worked you know seven
days a week I'll be working seven days a
week this week as well so it is a very
very um long unsocial uh job and I just
sometimes think it's it's important that
we also reflect the good work that MPS
do as well as some of the concerns
absolutely that's why the transparency
rules were brought in so that any
donation any income is there for
everyone to see and then constituents
can make their own minds up about
whether their constituency MP is working
hard for them okay
um well let's have a look now shall we
at the NHS um with your kind of Health
Minister hat out we've touched on it a
bit with your work at the Royal Marston
it feels to me like a lot of people
might be genuinely quite frightened
right now about the state of the house
service I mean we could just take a look
at this graph um this shows uh the
number of ambulances waiting longer than
an hour to hand over to patients so we
know what that means that's ambulances
backed up but outside hospitals with
people inside uh that can't get a bed
it's it's yeah it's concerning the red
line at the top is this current year and
you can see it's far higher than at any
point during the pandemic I mean this
isn't a Health Service that's in crisis
well winter is always a difficult time
you know my 25 years of nursing I but I
can see the comparison to other Winters
here it feels an exceptional winter it
is an exceptional winter and I was just
about to say that you know I've worked
in uh normal Winters when we've had
ambulances queuing and declared critical
incidents that the n e that I worked at
but this is a different Year we're
seeing a twin demic of both covid and
flu so we're seeing um even compared to
in the last decade the most fluid
mission that we've seen there's nearly
over five thousand people in hospital at
the moment with flu over 6 000 in
hospital with covid and many of those
are over 65 with lots of comorbidities
which means they're much more unwell in
hospital and that shows you the scale of
the numbers that we wouldn't normally
see even in the winter when we have
normal winter pressures and staff are
also facing those pressures we have
around 60 000 staff members in the NHS
off sick in any one day at the moment
because they too get respiratory on the
stairs covered flu and so that's also
having an impact on services so this is
a very very uh difficult winter even
compared to most usual ones I mean our
next guest who will hear from in a
moment Dr Adrian Boyle president of the
Royal College of emergency medicine he
believes there are around 300 to 500
unnecessary deaths every week because of
delays in emergency care do you expect
people are dying because of delays well
we know that this is a difficult winter
we know there are excess deaths for a
number of reasons you know the chief
medical officers
I don't recognize the figure that you've
you've quoted there but what I can say
is that we are working really really
hard to get people into hospital we know
that around 13 000 people are in
hospital in any one day that shouldn't
be
um that is a shifting group of people
that's not the same 13 000 every single
day if you look at December we've got 8
000 of those patients out of hospital
with care packages either to home or to
care homes or to other settings and yet
the next day another group of patients
are admitted really unwell with covid
with flu with respiratory illnesses and
they are often complex patients who
again will take time to discharge that's
why the Prime Minister held the Forum
yesterday with a range of health
professionals to see what more we can do
we've given 500 million this winter to
get Social care packages in place to get
people out of hospital because that's
the number one reason why ambulances are
stuck at the doors of a E's because they
can't unload their patients because a
E's can't discharge their patients to
the wards so that's why we're focusing
on social care you know when when I
interviewed people who work in the
Health Service I think that's a bit of a
frustration frankly at the government
trying to say that this is just because
of covid it's just because of an
exceptional flu year and they say it's
actually because of under investment in
the health service that goes back for
years and I just want to have a look at
this this is a funding chart and it
shows the annual changes in health
spending and you can really see that
from when the conservatives came into
power in 2010 there has been a four a
queer squeeze in funding for the Health
Service I mean you're a nurse you
obviously care deeply about the NHS do
you understand why people might be you
know angry I guess or you've missed off
for a couple of years there so to be
fair this is it's not been missed off
this is where it ends right well no so
we've increased by 11 the funding in the
last couple of years do you accept do
you accept that once 2010 between 2010
and 2020
there was a squeeze in funding for the
Health Service that people are now
saying in the House services is directly
related to shortage of beds a shortage
of doctors saying is that and the
Institute of fiscal Studies have
highlighted that and they're not exactly
Friends of the government that there's
record levels of investment there is an
11 increase in funding which is missing
off your chart that has meant that we're
opening up 7 000 new beds um in the NHS
it does mean we're recruiting over 10
000 more nurses which are in place now
so you're having to make up now for
under investment under previously we are
investing in record levels of funding
not just for the NHS but also for social
care and these issues that you see
around ambulances queuing up uh beds not
being available they're in all four
devolved Nations whether it's labor who
are running the NHS in Wales are facing
exactly the same pressures and sometimes
their performance in certain indicators
are worse than in England the UK
government just runs the Health Service
in England the SNP in Scotland are
facing exactly the same pressures
um and it's not just within the UK If
you look at other countries Ireland
Italy Spain
let's look at some other countries I
think we can also show so here we go
this is hospital beds per 100 000 people
the red line in the middle is the
average and then you have to go all the
way down only Sweden is lower than the
UK so if you're looking at International
comparison or hospital beds we're doing
pretty poorly so yeah again you're
looking at 2020 data in the last two the
latest we're opening up 7 000 new beds
uh within the NHS we're also opened we
have opened already over 90 surgical
hubs which is tackling our surgical
backlog of seven million people we've
cleared almost completely 13 years but
we've cleared almost completely the two
people waiting for two years or more for
their surgical waiting list we're on
track to meet those waiting 18 months by
April and then we'll be focusing on
those waiting for a year so to to you
know we need to look at the most
up-to-date figures seven thousand extra
beds will make a huge difference to the
NHS okay let's talk about strikes uh
shall we because the Prime Minister has
invited union leaders to have what he
calls grown-up honest talks tomorrow
there are going to be at these
conversations with their representative
departments is a house secretary
prepared to budge when it comes to pay
so the health secretary has invited the
unions to meet with him this week as
part of this initiative and it is to
talk about both pay and conditions he's
already met with uh Hey because that's a
shift it feels like before we talk about
conditions now the government is
prepared to move on but we want to talk
about pay uh the settlement for this
year because the government is about to
submit evidence the independent pay
review body for the pay award for this
year and I think it's really important
to have those discussions with the
unions about what's realistic but also
what they're they're looking for as well
so that we can send the most robust
information and evidence to the
independent pay review buddy that's a
clear change isn't it because previously
you were saying that it was conditions
that were on the table and now it's pay
and conditions well I think the
difference is we are now looking at this
year's pay pay award and we want to make
fast progress on that and we want to be
able to submit evidence to the pay
review bodies that the the unions uh
will also be submitting their evidence
too so that when the award is is made
that there should be hopefully a
consensus around what's awarded so we're
not looking at going back at post-dated
pay Awards we're really focused on the
pay awards for this year okay and now
just finally I want to talk to you with
your you know women and inequalities hat
on because the Scottish government has
passed new legislation to introduce
self-identification system for people
who want to change gender do you welcome
that or do you have concerns well I know
the Secretary of State Kami badinal
who's responsible overall for this area
has has some concerns and has written to
the Scottish government I know that they
are looking at that at the moment we do
have some concerns obviously we want to
make sure that for those people who want
to transition we're improving the
process and speeding up well it's quite
a clunky process at the moment but we
want to protect women's rights as well
and we have some concerns and that's why
kemi has written to the Scottish
government and is reviewing that at the
moment I just want to know how far
you're willing to go if you do have
those concerns because immediately after
the vote the Scottish secretary asked
Jack said the UK government had concerns
as you there in particular over what he
describes as safety issues for women
children and then he went on to say we
will look closely at that and also the
ramifications of the 2010 equality act
and other uk-wide legislation in the
coming weeks up to and including a
section 35 order stopping the bill going
for Royal Ascent so are you genuinely
considering blocking this bill in
Westminster well that'll be a matter for
cabinet and as you say the Scottish
secretary and Kenny badanok who's the
equalities secretary are looking at that
and having discussions the conservatives
are the only party that voted against
that legislation we do have concerns but
that will be a matter that will be
discussed at cabinet before the final
decision is taken okay but on the table
then well you know both the Scottish
secretary and the equality secretary
have indicated that